du hast die ja die union im blick mit
seiner these ganz genau und zwar kommt
mir die union vor allem die cdu aber
gerade vor wie ein veganer der aber
lieber verhungert als das saftiges steak
zu essen das neben ihm liegt diese site
heißt nun mal markus söder die
beliebtheitswerte von markus söder und
von armin laschet sind ja seit monaten
bekannt markus söder extrem hoch armin
laschet verheerend und die große
hoffnung von armin laschet und von
seinen spin doktoren war immer wenn
armin laschet erstmal kanzlerkandidat
ist dann gehen sodass beliebtheitswerte
auf ihn über das war ziemlich esoterisch
und hat natürlich auch überhaupt nicht
funktioniert die beliebtheitswerte von
armin laschet sind mittlerweile bei
unter zehn prozent es ist verheerend und
die union steht halt davor dutzende
vielleicht sogar über 100 mandate zu
verlieren die union steht davor in die
opposition abzurutschen also schlimmer
geht es nicht aber die union erwartet ja
noch etwas viel schlimmeres wenn man der
union selbst glauben kann die warnen vor
einem linksbündnis die waren jetzt seit
heute vor dem untergang europas wenn
olaf scholz kanzler wird dann frage ich
mich doch wenn euch das land von euch da
kontinent und eure eigene partei so
wichtig ist ja warum wählt hier nicht
einfach und warum nehmt ihr nicht
einfach den kandidaten der euch sofort
fünf bis zehn prozentpunkte mehr bringen
würde markus söder
also im april hätte ich diese rede
unterschrieben aber heute ist es zu spät
und vor allem dass das ist ein
klassischer fall vom kind mit dem bade
ausschütten ja also ich glaube das wäre
das wäre ein desaster er hat als
unvorstellbar dabei desaster für wen
für die cdu und auch für die union weil
die cdu damit in einer in eine
kapitulation aller hinein kommt ja die
unvorstellbar ist
die cdu als größere partei kann doch
nicht auf zwei wochen vor dem wahlkampf
ihren mühsam in was ihren fast
einjähriger hier
parteiveranstaltungen gewählten neuen
heute quasi fast noch neuen frischen
vorsitzenden einfach absetzen und durch
seinen gegner ersetzen der eine viel
kleinere partei repräsentiert und was
glauben sie denn die in norddeutschland
dann die cdu leute hier wahlkampf machen
würde ich dem markt sind er würde keine
weitere prozente holen ganz im gegenteil
wir hätten eine demotivierte eine eine
eine
eine partei eine cdu ohne
selbstwertgefühl
und das würde auf jahre hinaus hier die
diese union belasten und insgesamt die
konservative fraktion auf das
konservative politik in deutschland das
wäre die zerstörung der union und es
wäre
wahrscheinlich auch eine eine ganz
heftige will ich sagen zerstörung aber
beschädigung der cdu insgesamt also eine
zwischenfrage lieber verlieren mit
laschet als gewinn mit söder
lieberlieber verlieren als noch mal
verlieren also ich bin ich mir gar nicht
so sicher ist so extrem unbeliebt in
norddeutschland also ich lebe in hamburg
also darf man den namen gar nicht sagen
sie würden niemals in zolder akzeptieren
und in berlin eigentlich auch nicht
meine ganzen norddeutschen nördlichen
freunde also bin ich mir gar nicht so
sicher ob das schon das weiterhin haut
aber die umfragen sind jedoch relativ
eindeutig ja aber darf ich mal erinnern
an die erste wahl von angela merkel da
waren ihre persönlichkeitswerte auch
katastrophale öffentliches bild war ein
1 1 sport bild in der nation und in der
union gab es die debatte muss sich
roland koch das machen ein gestandener
oder friedrich merz und da war gab es
eine ähnliche debatte und die
politprofis haben gesagt ja wieso nimmt
die cdu diese frau die hat doch so
schlechte zustimmungswerte und ist noch
ungelenk und unerfahren und am ende hat
sie knapp gewonnen und wir haben gesehen
was für eine kanzlerschaft daraus wurde
wenn jemand 16 jahre so regiert dann
muss er auch ein paar sachen richtig
gemacht und ich muss auch sagen das wäre
ja auch ein zeichen von totaler
führungsschwäche hier der cdu aber es
ist halt einfach die wahrheit
für euch sind die umfragen quasi hier
das eingemeißelt situationen das sind
die nicht und die leute spüren
irgendwann mal wenn jemand nur schafft
sein fähnchen immer nur nach dem wind
hängt ja und war auf die umfragen
reagiert oder ob er vielleicht in einer
schwierigen situation mal seinen mann
steht oder
ihre frau steht und führungsstärke
beweist und auch gute nerven beweisen
und das hat das muss ich mir lassen der
schon einmal bei der wahl in
nordrhein-westfalen bewiesen die all
gewonnen hat dagegen auf wieder um
fragen wie wir die mit der amtierende
ministerpräsident natürlich selber
erledigt aber diese situation war im
april eigentlich da muss man sagen die
hätte sünde in der hand gehabt als sie
hier nachts im reichstag saßen es ist
jetzt alles dokumentiert wie das genau
war mit scholl play in einem
abgedunkelten raum und dobrindt
versuchte den den sünder durchzubringen
in der fraktion waren die
abstimmungskarten schon gedruckt in der
fraktion von cdu und csu hatte söder
eine eindeutige mehrheit er hätte am
nächsten morgen die abstimmung erzwingen
können wie damals franz josef strauß
gegen albrecht er hat es nicht gemacht
er hat es nicht gemacht wenn er in
dieser situation den mund ich hat
durchzuziehen dann kann er jetzt nicht
beantragen sollen acht jetzt wechselt
mich nochmal ein auf spielfeld er
beantragt das ja auch gar nicht aber
diese diese ominöse runde mit wolfgang
schäuble mit volker bouffier also diese
cdu-granden die damals armin laschet ja
auch zum kanzlerkandidaten gemacht haben
an deren stelle hätte ich jetzt angst
denn ihre namen stehen sofort auf der
liste direkt unter armin laschet wenn es
darum geht wer fällt wenn die cdu
verliert das stimmt vor allen dingen es
kann auch sein dass wirklich kein
bundespräsident mehr bleibt dass die cdu
wenn sie wirklich so schlecht
abschneidet wie es jetzt eine umfrage
letzte woche hatte dass sie alle ämter
verlieren das kann gut sein deswegen an
der stelle der cdu würde ich mir
wahnsinnige sorgen machen und es ging es
ging ja nicht um rache oder das nur
umfrage also man ist kein fähnchen nach
dem wind sondern die stimmung an der
basis die stimmung an der fraktion
übrigens auch in den norddeutschen
bundesländern die war ja eindeutig für
markus söder vielleicht würde man jetzt
einfach ein historisches fehlurteil
korrigieren bevor es jetzt wirklich zu
einer historischen klappt dann ist es zu
spät sie haben sich 14 tage vor der wahl
ja ja das geht wirklich
so viel erfahrung als investor wenn die
union der aktie wäre würdest du jetzt
kaufen na ja man kann sagen das sind
kaufkurse
also jetzt haben wir jedoch auch gesagt
doch keiner gekauft im frühjahr
vielleicht gar nicht wollen sicher
dieses jahr merke dass er politik und
dieses jahr lehrt auch das sind
überraschende bewegung da wie noch nie
die aktie der burg die war doch der
highflyer überhaupt genau und dann war
die aktie laschet war ganz oben und
jetzt dreht sich das deswegen das spiel
ist noch nicht vorbei war das heißt ja
beide gibt ja ja
microscan
dessen generalsekretär hat ja etwas
bemerkenswertes gemacht in einem spiegel
interview hatte er gesagt natürlich
werden wir mit markus söder besser dran
und aus dem interview geht auch vor das
plakat ideen jedenfalls vielleicht sogar
plakate schon bereit standen wie weg das
auf euch wer sagt die wahrheit da bin
ich bei pia topf natürlich wäre so
wieder der bessere kandidat er sagt die
wahrheit er muss als generalsekretäre
natürlich seinen landes jahren immer als
den könig alles herausholen insofern das
finde ich jetzt nicht so gibt es denn
eine größere stinkbombe so kurz vor der
wahl in der union als die dass man heute
maximal öffentlich noch mal sagt der
andere wenn der besserung ist er also
ich finde das unterstellt als es so was
geht nicht in einer union auf gut
bayerisch hinterfotzig ja sowas macht
man doch nicht zwei wochen vor der wahl
wo alle in schwer wurde die eigene
parteien schwierigkeiten ist ja wie die
csu glänzt ja auch nicht gerade in
bayern ja das sind ja auch
wahrscheinlich unter 30 prozent erstmal
in den umfragen also die können da jetzt
auch noch nicht so so triumphal
auftreten ich finde einen partner einem
langjährigen partner kurz vor der wahl
so in den rücken zu fallen das ist
unanständig aber da geht es nicht um
triumph die versuchen sich einfach zu
retten vor armin laschet die wollen sich
jetzt vor der wahl einfach distanzieren
der hand dem adenauer haus war man
schockiert man hat das überhaupt nicht
kommen sehen jetzt hat man so richtig
angst vor allem die lasche auftritt am
samstag in nürnberg weil man auch nicht
weiß was ihn da erwartet gefahren hin
als würden sie nicht zu ihrer
schwesterpartei fahren sondern als
würden sie in offene schlacht laufen und
sie wissen nicht mal wer die
gegnerischen truppen sind also so was
hat man der union wirklich lange nicht
mehr gesehen ich glaube dass
überschätzen sie weil jeder abgeordnete
csu will auch in den bundestags geht
auch um deren jobs die gerade weinten
deswegen kämpfen die moment schon auch
um jede stimme absolut die kämpfen aber
vielleicht glauben sie einfach nicht
mehr daran dass sie es schaffen und
jetzt gilt nun mal die parole lieber
rechtzeitig distanzieren um dann nicht
in mithaftung genommen zu werden
andererseits kann das auch glaube ich
abend füllen schief gehen ich habe als
ich das gelesen habe und von blume habe
ich gedacht die müssen sich sicher sein
das ist doch noch zum wechsel des
kandidaten kommt weil es sonst es der
vorstoß komplett verrückt weil er
nämlich armin laschet im falle einer
niederlage komplett erleichtert dann ist
nämlich nicht nur armin laschet schuld
sondern auch quasi die
hinterfotzig der schwesterpartei ihm
kurz vorher in rücken zu fallen also
deswegen ich hab immer noch so eine
innere stimme die sagt der wechsel kommt
noch und zwar weil bouffier und schäuble
heute abend auf armin laschet einfluss
nehmen und sagen armin lassen uns noch
mal neu denken und ich sage es jetzt
nochmal weil die alle ihr seid alle so
ich verstehe ich jetzt auch alle sport
affin und so ist 80 minute du kannst du
stürmer einwechseln und so schaut so
wieder runter gerissen und ich will noch
mal einen sagen auch ein bisschen
sozusagen kritisch unserer profession
gegen es ist doch an dem satz oder an
der wand handle an dem bekenntnis von
armin laschet nicht schlimm mehr noch
sehr viel ehren wert wenn der am sonntag
vielleicht sogar beim parteitag der csu
folgendes erklärt ich bin der
vorsitzende der cdu ich habe das
vorschlagsrecht für den
kanzlerkandidaten
ich habe
wahlkampf begonnen und ich sehe wir
haben mit mir nicht die chancen die wir
brauchen und die wir unbedingt für die
zukunft des landes brauchen und deshalb
schlage ich vor dass wir jetzt mit
markus in dienten den endspurt des
wahlkampfs geht ist eine riesen nummer
geht er geht er sozusagen mit einem mit
einem seminar bezeugung vom platz und
wir schreiben dann ein bisschen was von
niederlage und so das kann man aber ja
quasi das wäre doch jetzt die handlung
eines verantwortungsvollen parteichefs
anstatt zu sagen ich halte an mir fest
und ab in den abgrund
das ist so
unpolitisch gedacht zumal ein lascher
designer in seiner karriere als helfer
bei riesen hat in der letzten minute ist
seine stärkste zeit hat seine
wesentlichen karriereschritte immer mit
den last minute moves gewonnen und er
glaubt fest daran und wenn es gut geht
und er ist an kanzler dann wären wir
kommen er hat die nerven behalten die
nerven nicht verloren und mein haupt mal
glaubt wirklich ich bleibe im bild ihr
glaubt wirklich der zweimal gelb
verwarnte mit einem pferdekuss im
rechten oberschenkel und keinem linken
bein mehr der schaft noch den sieger
sowie schweinsteiger zum endspiel ja
also lange mitmacht den schweinsteiger
als das land und heute
laschet macht den schweinsteiger oder
philipp lahm kann es mir nicht
vorstellen tatsächlich deine theorie
welche total zustimme die ist
tatsächlich viel zu politisch weil es
auch zeigt dass die punkte aber ich habe
leider völlig unpolitisch ja wenn du
kannst dich 14 tage
manager von unternehmen und hat es ihr
wisst doch was man alles sagen aber ist
es wichtig eine solche macht es nur alle
ämter um in aller öffentlichkeit kann
eine selbstbewusste partei wie die cdu
nicht das wäre eine selbstdemontage ja
absolut glaube ich ein leben nicht das
wäre auch die grünen hätten das macht er
schon im mai weil sie beide aus einer
partei kommen weil sie die partei als
als dubai geführt haben über über jahre
und das zu diesem punkt gebracht haben
da hätte die baerbock sagen können ich
sehe ein wir spielen immer im doppel
aber ich lass doch den robert gates vor
da hätte das funktionieren es würde bei
nichts mentalität von papas stimmt
mittel stufenleiterin sieht es in ihrem
ehrgeiz nicht vor
[Musik]